joining us tonight to talk about this
and to give us some tremendous insights
we're already talking quite a bit about
what's going on with Trump's legal
Affairs we've got Sean Spicer good to be
with you guys again I'm excited to be
back brand new show coming out Monday
the Sean Spicer show uh right down on
YouTube Sean M Spicer Rumble but if you
go to Sean Spicer show.com you can get
it on any platform we're also going to
be on the first which is great so all
platforms uh Monday and as I said well
before we went on air the great thing is
primaries caucuses conventions debates
the race for 270. I'm gonna break it
down every day what are the rules and
how can we win I think too often the
right doesn't get what it takes to win
we need to know the rules if we're
actually going to win so I'm excited to
be here tonight absolutely plus uh as I
mentioned just before the show we were
already talking about what goes into
these legal challenges the amount of
time energy the hundreds of thousands of
dollars and uh it was starting to get
good I'm like we better hold on because
uh you were agreeing to an extent that
we ain't seen nothing yet